so engulfed obviously the idea is you're
supposed to get the ball in the hole
with as few strokes as possible and in
code golf you're supposed to write a
program that does something with as few
keystrokes as possible I guess right
with these few characters as possible so
you're trying to produce the shortest
possible program that does a particular
thing and it's a kind of a nerd sport
you know
although this is a very bad practice
like if you're really writing software
generally speaking you do not want the
source code to be as small as possible
right there are things sometimes you do
want that's what's going to be small but
you have things like minifiers that will
deliberately you know programs that will
automatically compress code this
actually is just an example of a
deliberately very short bit of code this
is the code here and this is the whole
of it and it plays a piece of music
which I'm not exactly sure how long it
lasts
definitely 16 minutes possibly more like
30 minutes before it starts to actually
repeat itself so it produces a fairly
large amount of complexity the song is
quite repetitive but well I'll play it
so this is
starts off very simple
and then becomes more complex with time
all of the instruments are essentially
the same but with different parameters
so we can go into the code a little bit
we send the source code to make a C
program that will generate audio data
and then we're running it and playing
that audio data fairly straightforward
as a structure yeah and then that's what
you get it takes a few minutes to get
actually good so so when you run it
though I'd see one or two warnings
possible they just just pay no attention
to most of this is the compiler
complaining that we are torturing the C
language uh-huh
when C is really kind of permissive it
lets you get away with an enormous
amount that you really shouldn't be able
to so here for example all of these
defaults to int it turns out that if you
see C as a strongly typed language right
every variable has to have a type if
that's an integer or a float or a
character or a pointer or whatever but
it turns out that if you don't specify
that in principle you have to specify it
but if you don't it just goes oh you
haven't specified it I'll assume it's an
int so which is just an integer so
everything every variable in here is an
integer because that way we don't have
to waste any characters specifying what
it is and integers work fine for this so
this program really has two main parts
there's a function here called G and
then there's a big loop which calls that
function several times and then calls
put char which prints a character to the
output so if we remove the pipe to a
play rather than piping the audio data
to the speakers it will just pipe it to
the screen and we can look at it and it
looks like this kind of fun
so you can see there's kind of structure
to it there's a pattern it's not random
noise there's kind of waveforms almost
in chiptune music you tend to have a few
basic waveforms that people use all the
time because they're easy to generate
right one of them is the square wave
that has a particular sound which you
recognize from the old-time game music
there's also the triangle wave which is
sounds a bit like a sine wave but is
much easier to generate than a sine wave
because it doesn't have that complicated
curvy stuff and the other one is the
sawtooth wave which is one that goes up
and then jumps down and up and jumps
down right kind of looks like the teeth
of a saw and this works by sawtooth
waves because it turns out sawtooth
waves are super easy to produce just by
overflow what does it mean to say you
were overflowing an n-bit representation
you have a fixed number of bits in your
number and then you get up to 1 1 1 1 1
1 1 and if you add one to it you do 1 is
1 0 carry the 1 carry the 1 carry the 1
carry the 1 carry the 1 and then you're
carrying off the end and there's nothing
there so the thing gets reset to 0 so
what this is doing in its loop is
there's a constant loop here and then
put sha is expecting a char chars are
only eight bits right 8-bit characters
so the way that put trial works is that
you give it 256 that's like giving it 0
so by having this number that keeps
going up going into put char you end up
with this sort of shape right the number
goes up and up and up until it goes off
the scale and starts again at the bottom
so this is the core on which the thing
is built we just have a really simple
loop we're incrementing I every time
then we're putting you at out as a
character and printing it so if we look
at that as it comes out it's just this
and in fact you can see look it's very
neat this is what happens if you just
output increasingly higher numbers at
the beginning you have a bunch of
control codes which don't print and then
you start getting into the characters
you get punctuation then the numbers
upper case and then lower case these are
unprintable again because we've gone off
the end of asking it only uses the first
half and then it loops around again so
this is the output of that program if we
then pipe that to a play
we get that rather lovely sound because
the way that a play works is it says in
fact it even tells us which is kind of
nice
playing raw data from standard input
unsigned 8-bit at 8000 Hertz so what
that's doing is saying okay I'm reading
an unsigned 8-bit is the same as a
character I'm reading in one character
at a time 8,000 in a second and I'm
treating the value of each character as
sort of the position that the diaphragm
of the speaker should be at at that at
that eight thousandth of a second so if
you tell it this this these 256 values
up to 0 and down again you get whatever
it is a thousand divided by 256 and
let's do that what is that I can't do
maths you get a approximately 31 Hertz
square wave and in fact we could
probably test that let's see there we
are it's a b0 31.3 Hertz and that's the
core idea of how this works now if we
wanted to make that higher pitched
we just need to increase the rate at
which the number goes up right so if
instead of printing AI we printed I star
2 for example what does that mean star 2
multiplied by 2 so now if we look at it
it should skip every other one so rather
than having 0 1 2 3 we have 0 2 4 6 8
because it's skipping them out so it's
going twice as steeply so this ought to
be about 60 Hertz it's twice as high and
we can look at it
there now to be one 62.5 votes and by
this basic function by multiplying this
by different values you can get any
pitch you want and that's the core of
how this makes music I'm seeing your
code then I'm thinking there's not 16
minutes worth of notes there so what's
going actually on it runs this loop and
then the printer character and the way
it gets that character is by calling
this function G four times one for each
instrument and just adding up the
results because in sound if you take one
waveform and just superimpose and just
add the other waveform on top that just
makes the sound of both of them one of
the arguments you pass into the
instrument function is the volume that
that instrument should play at and that
is set by bit shifting the the
incremented variable I by a very large
number bit shifting is an operation a
binary operation where you take your
number and you sort of move the decimal
place one point left or right in
principle so in in decimal if you were
doing a shift of that sort you would be
multiplying or dividing by ten right by
either chopping digits off the end or
adding zeros and in binary what you're
very effectively doing is having or
doubling and it's a very very fast
efficient way of having a doubling up
music kind of works on doubling and
halving in a sense write a lot of music
so we can use this to get numbers which
very very slowly relatively speaking so
you have your you have your number which
is the level of your sawtooth waves
which is going up very quickly one every
sink you know eight thousand times a
second and then if you right shift that
for example seventeen times you get
something that only happens once every
two to the seventeen samples which is I
don't know why I don't off the top my
head went in 17 years but it's a pretty
big number that then allows you to have
something for example where it changes
from one bar to the next it lets you
have slow changing sections so that you
can you can have a note that lasts a
certain number of samples or a bar that
lasts a certain number of samples or a
phrase the last a certain number of
samples and the way that the music is
structured
they're always even powers of two and it
just so happens that that works out
quite neatly musically
we'd like to thank audible.com for
sponsoring this episode of computerphile
if you visit audible.com slash
computerphile you can sign up for 30-day
free trial
they've got over 180,000 books to choose
from it's really straightforward you can
browse by category or you can search by
title or author today I'd like to
recommend the Curious Incident of the
dog in the night-time she's a curious
title in its own right it's a book by
Mark Haddon it centers on a boy with
Asperger's syndrome people without
Asperger's syndrome can probably work
out by intuition what's actually
happened and so you kind of know what's
happened but what you get to see in the
book is how the boy works out what's
happened for himself so thanks again to
audible.com for sponsoring this episode
of computerphile remember audible.com
slash computerphile
sign up for 30 days free I find it kind
of calming to listen to like I found
when I was working on it I would just
kind of zone out and listen to it for 10
minutes
okay I want to change this or I think I
can make this bit shorter right
something like that